avec noir direct monsieur luc ferrandez
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy d'abord
félicitations pour votre réélection
merci est ce que vous vous vers la fin
vous aviez dit je crois je sais pas où
c'est comme c'est comme l'ancien 25 sous
alors l'air je mène pas sur vous c'est
ainsi que c'était plus serré cette fois
mais en fait oui parce que là les
manifestants parlait avec une voix
tellement fort n'y a pas une journée où
on n'a pas parlé dans les médias de la
grogne des habitants du plateau où on
n'a pas au plein gong prétendu des
évidences bateau où on a du chalet très
mal pour moi alors un moment donné il
faudra que je prête l'oreille mais moi
j'étais convaincu que les résidences
bateau allait accepter le projet
collectif qu'on leur proposait et c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait et c'est extrêmement
fier donc comment vous comprenez cette
victoire les gens vous disent dans le
fond pour y en a que ça fait pas leur
affaire mais les résidants du plateau
montréal ce qui coachent là le soir ils
sont plutôt contents que vous viendriez
qu'elle est beau parquet et c'est tout
simplement des boues par monsieur roy
moi je veux pas minimiser la grande
chose qu'ils ont fait ce soir ils ont
voté pour un projet collectif en
acceptant des contrats individuels et ça
c'est magique
au lieu de penser que l'heure
l'arrondissement la ville sera là pour
les servir servir leurs besoins un
parent et ziz nous on croit on accepte
les contraintes à condition que ce
quartier l'offre s'enrichit depuis que
d'enrichir se développe s'épanouissent
et que cet enrichissement la haye dans
le sens où si d'un grand projet global
que de projet environnemental
un projet humaniste et savez c'est la
population du plateau mont royal que je
connais que j'ai connus y sont comme ça
je les adore merci merci merci
se faire des cheveux vous entendent
avant de vous laisser fêter avec vous
les jeunes vous adorez ah je vous
entends sur denis coderre nouveau maire
de montréal comment comment ça va se
passer la chimie
excusez moi c'est moi tu parles en
arrière nous écoute qu'il est resté avec
moi
comment ça fonctionne et comment vous
voyez l'élection de denis coderre que
vous pouvez vous entendre sur plusieurs
points comment ça va fonctionner mais
premièrement monsieur denis cosnard il
va arriver pour un premier mandat comme
maire de montréal il va faire face à une
réalité qui est la réalité des
arrondissements il va devoir négocier
avec nous il va devoir s'asseoir et nous
on est prêt à s'asseoir on va devoir
envoyer le login sont des personnes
intelligentes nous allons arriver à des
résultats
bon ça car même que la poignée de main
doit être ferme là oui je trouvais
toujours au moins vous répondez toujours
aux questions monsieur ferrandez son
globe de naissance alors on va suivre la
suédé chômé en 20 secondes n'allait pas
accélérer vos réformes sur le plateau ne
vous allez pas lancer les voitures à
l'extérieur du vote arrondissement mais
monsieur roy plus que jamais on va
appliquer notre programme
bon je suis ferrandez merci d'avoir été
là en direct à la prochaine que moi qui
vous c'est moi qui vous remercie donc
c'est très clair on va en parler après
monsieur ferrandez ceux qui pensaient
qu'elle à mettre de l'eau dans son vin
sur le plateau après cette élection là
il sent qu'il a le vent dans le dos et
avec denis coderre on aimerait être là
lors de la première réunion
véronique